الانترنت حول العالم ما له سيره غير
شاكيرا وبيكي من ثلاثه ايام والسبب اغنيه
النجمه اللي متصدر الاخبار والعناوين من
وقت اطلاقها ويمكن نقدر نسميها نوع من
انواع الانتقام الموسيقي الاكثر قوه صراحه
ومن وقت ما نزلت بتحقق ارقام قياسيه
فالاغنيه ترند رقم واحد في العالم على
يوتيوب وللقان عليها ما يزيد عن 110 مليون
مشاهده خلال ثلاثه ايام بس لكن ليش انا
سميتها انتقام موسيقي لانه كلمات ببساطه
نوع من الانتقام والرسائل المبطنه للعب
الاسباني
واللي انفصلت عنه شاكيرا السنه الماضيه
بعد علاقه اكثر من 10 سنين كانوا الناتج
منها حتى في ولدين وسبب الانفصال كان
خيانه شاكيرا مع موظفه في احدى شركاته او
هذه القصه المتداوله او المعتمده وكان
رايح ينتهي الحال فيهم في المحاكم بخصوص
حضانه الاولاد وامور اخرى لك نجحوا انهم
ينهلوا الامور بالتسويه من وقت الانفصال
شاكيرا ساكته تماما وما تكلمت في اللي صار
ابدا وبيكا كمان ما صرح او اتكلم في شيء
لكن في كل مكان داير مع صاحبه الجديده
وصورهم وهم في احضان بعض في كل مكان
شاكيرا من الاول ساكته ويبدو انه اختارت
تقول كل اللي في قلبها عن طريق الاغنيه
[موسيقى]
اه
استاذ مكه
[موسيقى]
يعني ما بتكلم اسبانيا مو فاهم وين
الانتقام هيكون في الموضوع بس انا خليني
اوريكم فين واترجم لكم بعض اجزاء الاغنيه
يعني جمل تحديدا شاكيرا بتقول في الاغنيه
انا كثير عليك وعلى شان كده انت رحت لاحد
من حجمك وقيمتك ما راح ارجع لك لو بكيت
وتوصلت وبتقول كمان يا ريت مثل ما بتدرب
جسمك في الجيم تدرب عقلك كمان وبتمنى لك
التوفيق مع بديلتي المفترضه وبتقول انا
بقيمه اثنين من بنات ال 22 شاكيرا للتذكير
عمرها 45 سنه وصحبه بيكي الجديده عمرها 23
سنه وقالت كمان بدلت الفيراري
بتنجويكس بيكاسو صغيره كيوت كده من
الانتاج والفراري طبعا معروفه وكاسيو ساعه
ممكن نقول سعرها في متناول المعظم
وبك اكيد كمان ما عجب المقطع يعني او ما
عجبت الاغنيه فالاثنين اجتمعوا احبوا يعني
يستفيدوا من الموقف ويعطونا درس في فن
اقتناص الفرس
يوكل لكن نسيكم لكن
[موسيقى]
كابرس
[ضحك]
خلال جلسه بث مباشر مع اعضاء دوري كنز ليج
بي بي كي اعلن عن التعاقد مع شركه كاسيو
وقال انها ساعات بتدوم مدى الحياه وعلى
تويتر في حساب ساخر يناسب نفسه لشركه
كاسيو على اكثر من 200,000 متابع شغال نكت
ومسخره على شاكيرا
رينو كمان حبه تستفيد في نشرت اعلان
السياره في تغريده بكلمات من اغنيه شاكيرا
وعلى الباب رقم 22 اللي شاكيرا غنت له
وهشتاقات من كلمات الاغنيه كمان